were
[Music]
the ukrainian women and children akshank
sharma shows videos of him and his
fellow students fleeing the russian
bombing of kharkiv the 20 year old was
in his first year of medical school in
the eastern ukrainian city he's one of
nearly 18 000 indian medical students
evacuated from ukraine since the russian
invasion began
last year
i passed the entrance exam last year but
i didn't have enough marks to go to
government college here because their
cut-off requirements are very high so
the better option for me was to go
overseas
like akshayang sisters monica and anshul
bhatti said they were forced to study
overseas where fees are much cheaper
their family says they're paying half
the amount of fees in ukraine than they
would in private colleges in india
online classes have begun for the
sisters and some others but they're not
ideally
[Music]
the problem with online is that we need
a lot of practical experience which we
aren't able to do we are a third year
student and practical is very important
in the third year so it's difficult
the return of the students from ukraine
is again putting the spotlight on the
lack of medical colleges in india
the number of seats available for
medical education in india is far less
than the number of students who leave
school with the hope of becoming doctors
of the 1.6 million who did the entrance
exam last year only 88 000 made it into
the 562
medical colleges in the country
given the shortage private colleges
charge hefty fees for the much
sought-after spaces and receive large
donations from students families
public health experts blame a lack of
government investment in health care and
what they call the medical council of
india's arbitrary regulations to set up
colleges
whether it was a bonafide
intent to protect standards as they said
or whether it was to protect some
interests of people who are running
private medical colleges i cannot really
say
however
that did result in a smaller number of
medical colleges and also a clustering
of medical colleges
in the four southern states and two
western indian states
prime minister narendra modi blamed
previous governments for the lack of
colleges and said his administration
will increase the number
as students who've returned from ukraine
appealed to the government to find a way
for them to continue their studies at
home
some health experts say it's an ideal
opportunity for india to tackle the
doctor shortage elizabeth paranam al
jazeera greater noida uttar pradesh